there are real problems right like the
woke stuff and gender transitioning and
all that like it's an important cultural
thing because it's connected to
censorship and Free Speech right the
obsession the the idea that any of us
have to talk about this trans stuff is
is sort of ridiculous because in a sane
Society it's such a tiny amount of
people and whatever you do again as an
adult it just shouldn't matter we have
real issues real issues would include
the fact that our border is open and we
all know it and we had more border
crossings this year than any other year
in American history Joe Biden refuses to
go down to the border and when a certain
orange man a couple years ago used to
talk about a border and try to build a
wall they said he was racist that's the
same guy
that when he said we should stop flights
from China because of kovid they said he
was racist about that but just in the
last couple days the Biden
Administration has now extended I think
until April of 2023 if you're coming
from China you have to have a negative
covet test sounds a little racist to me
but you know what are we going to do
anyway uh here is black lesbian press
secretary Corrine Jean-Pierre uh telling
uh Steve Ducey uh no Peter Ducey sorry
Steve the dad Peter Ducey that Biden is
focused on the border and this is
somehow Republican's fault
does anybody around here think that the
southern border is secure
what I can tell you is this is a
president has been working since day one
uh to work on border security uh to make
an immigration a priority that's why he
put forth a comprehensive immigration uh
reform plan legislation and here's
here's the thing as the president is
coming forward and trying to come up
with Solutions but the difference here
is that you have Republicans as you know
who are doing political stunts okay so
just like meaningless dribble right like
she just nothing from day one the
Republic you know the president's Been
Working On The Border and it's just like
he refuses to go down there we know they
are letting all these people in they put
you know all of these border towns have
massive Jeopardy and nobody cares but if
you send 30 people up to Martha's
Vineyard all hell is going to break
loose